this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists today
we're going to talk about owning less
we're going to talk about wanting less
we're going to talk about decluttering
physical and digital spaces
we're going to talk about more about
less
got a lot to talk about today a lot of
questions to answer and we're here
with ronaldo banks ron thanks for
joining us thank you thanks for having
me this is exciting it's great to have
you man first time in la so
this is your first time in l.a first
time here first time here
even though it's during the pandemic
some of like our favorite restaurants
are still open
i wrote down four for him yeah oh this
how long are you guys in town
tomorrow morning okay yeah so we have
this afternoon to explore you got at
least two meals
yeah at least five thousand calories
right over these four restaurants that
i'm going to recommend
perfect that's awesome ron i really like
your youtube channel that's why you're
here today
you do a great job with um with your
videos we'll be talking more about your
videos i do want to encourage folks to
check it out we'll put a link
to your channel in the show notes or you
can just go to youtube
type in ronald l banks you'll find all
of his minimalism videos there also some
poetry videos
uh which we can talk about uh in fact i
want to talk specifically about some of
your
videos i want to go into detail on some
of those we'll get to those but
this is a listener driven show so i
figured we start out with some questions
our first question is from chris in fort
collins colorado
i have a two-part question one is
what criteria do you use uh to make any
purchases
and the second question is what is your
opinion
on upgrading things that you currently
own
to you know something that you think
would make you happier
or something like that now ron i want to
get your your
thoughts on this but here are some
things i'll just set it up like this
because i have some definitive answers
for this quite often
people will call in and they'll ask a
rather esoteric question and that we
have to
try to work through it but we've already
written about this
quite a bit but here's here's the simple
answer for the first part of chris's
question
how do you decide how do you be more
intentional with your purchases
there are five questions that ryan and i
ask before we buy something
i'll go through those questions real
quick it's uh can i afford to part with
this money
and so i i think can i afford the thing
right it is is a question you know
obviously if i have to put it on a
credit card i can't afford the things if
i have to finance it i can't afford the
thing and i know some people would like
what about
a a car i gotta okay if you have to by
definition if you have to finance
something you can't afford it right
because you could afford it you would
just
pay cash right you would buy the thing
right so
so that's the first question the second
question is can i pay the actual cost
remember that the true
cost of a thing is well beyond the price
tag so
storing the thing cleaning the thing
changing the batteries or the oil and
the thing putting gas in the thing
the electricity for the thing the the
the space that
it takes up in your mind all these
things are additional costs that
we don't think about because we see the
you know the the item we want to buy and
it's like oh it's 50 bucks
but it's not 50 bucks it's it's so much
more than that
because you have to worry about it you
have there's a psychological cost or all
these other costs
will it add value to my life is the next
question and really when
we say we'll add value will serve a
purpose or bring me joy
now you can justify anything so you can
pretend something's really going to
serve a purpose of bringing joy but you
have to be honest with yourself with
some of these things because otherwise
we'll just let anything in right
the fourth question is what are the
alternatives
and i think sometimes we don't even
think about that what
what else can i do with this money right
so if i'm going to spend 100 on a shirt
is that the best use of
of this money and then finally can i get
by without it for a while
i think it's one of the the messages of
minimalism here is if you didn't need it
five minutes ago maybe you don't need it
now
and and so uh maybe i'll just wait a
little bit and we have another we have a
rule
called the 30 30 rule if we if it costs
more than 30 bucks maybe i'll wait 30
hours it just try to put some time
between myself and the purchase so i'm
not making the
the impulse purchase so chris if you
want um we have a
a wallpaper for your phone so you can
have all five of those questions
right there on your phone anytime you go
to make a purchase you're standing in
line somewhere
it's free over at the minimalists.com
wallpapers
uh but i do want to talk about this this
idea of upgrading with you ron um
and so because i know you've talked
about this in the past what are your
thoughts on on upgrades
oh it's a good question uh personally i
don't upgrade much of anything
i'm still rocking the iphone 6. so if
you ask
most of the iphone fans i'm well behind
the eight ball on that one
but i think when it comes to upgrades or
purchasing in general um i try to look
at it from a perspective of who am i
buying this for mm-hmm i'm gonna find it
for me or the other people
so a big thing for me and why i started
this journey was kind of get away from
the idea of comparison and doing things
for other people i talked about in my
content how
i had this persona that i let go of this
mr smooth persona that
uh was given to me in high school and
that came with a lot of
additions of physical clutter the mental
clutter emotional
clutter things that i would just hold on
to because
one i didn't know how to let it go but
two just trying to uphold this
vision or this standard of other people
had it for me so um
for me you know the question is who am i
buying this thing for so am i buying it
for me
or am i buying it for those that think i
need to have it or those that also have
it
isn't it funny though because we do that
to impress other people
but usually they don't even care they
don't we just think they do right we
don't
and that that's that's the the irony of
it all is because
we look for validation out of our
friendships our relationships
but then most times those friendship
relationships aren't genuine they're
just based on the things we own
so if you don't have those things you
don't have those relationships so i
think you need to build those first
and allow what you need in your life to
be what you need in your life absolutely
you know what's interesting uh you
mentioned the validation
i was having this conversation the other
day and there's actually a video you
talk about how
uh you kind of created this um
the the urge to live a simple life and
uh we'll probably get to that later but
the validation when we look at uh our
friends when we look at uh our neighbors
or the joneses
we're looking for validation in the
wrong place like we we first have to
validate ourselves like that internal
validation
that is what matters and if we don't
have that it's never going to be enough
from anywhere else but i'll tell you
what though i still have the i've got
the 5s
which i think came out after the six so
you're still like one
you're still more minimalist why would
the 5s come out out after the six
i don't know but i'm pretty i'm pretty
sure it did but uh but any but anyway um
uh i was using that i was using that 5s
and someone was
they saw me use it they're like oh i
love that you have that old iphone
so if you hold on to it long enough it
actually becomes right
it's right the seeks after i think the
other thing to add to that is
is we kind of you talked about
validation and there's a piece of my
content i talk about the reality check
that simple living and decluttering
gives us and there's a question that i
always pose
i say who would you be if you had
nothing but yourself in the mirror in
front of you
so if you had none of the the excessive
clutter or the things or the newest
phone or the
the you know the shoes the clothes just
you in the mirror who would you be
and if you can't answer that question
then you're using those things to define
yourself yeah it doesn't matter what you
buy it doesn't matter yeah it doesn't
matter what vacation you go on yeah
you can't look at yourself in the mirror
then yeah why does it matter yeah right
and
i mean i still get roasted all the time
for our documentary minimalism if you
see my apartment in there there's
i own next to nothing at the time now i
was a single guy at the time and and
when we filmed that and so things were a
little bit different you know i have a
family now and that requires different
things as our life changes
and what i realized whenever even now
it's like during the pandemic they're
like
i bet those those minimalist guys
they're really regretting getting rid of
all their stuff
and it's like oh yeah i really miss the
broken waffle iron right and the old
bowling trophies
i didn't even know you bold yeah i mean
either i bought the bowling trophies
from goodwill
um and so like i i don't
what i realized there is like oh like
what they're saying is they would miss
the things and if so that's fine i'm not
i'm not here proselytizing i don't want
you to get rid of something if you're
completely contented
by the status quo then of course don't
don't deprive yourself of things but
maybe you can temporarily remove some
things from your life
for that short period of time and
realize like oh maybe the things i
thought were adding value to my life
are actually getting in the way of the
things that will add value to my life
chris i want to send you a copy of our
free ebook it's called
the minimalist rule book 16 rules for
living with less and one of those
rules is the don't upgrade rule
and we talk about some of the sometimes
you
if you do have to upgrade there are
three ways you can you can sort of go
without you can repair it or you replace
it
and so we talk about that don't upgrade
rule there are also some other rules in
there that will really
apply to you the 30 30 rule the 2020
rule the 90 90 rule
and a bunch of others that's free over
the minimalists.com
rule book i hope you enjoy that chris
can you men think of anything
that you've upgraded that you were like
i'm so glad i upgraded this
because i'm like really trying to find
that exception
it depends so let's talk about time
frames real quick so so i think in the
moment
usually the answer to that is yes like
if you go yeah if i were to go to the
apple store right now
and they give me the iphone 13 or
whatever the new thing is
in the moment i'm going to be like yes
that new box there's something about
that new box
yeah taking off the shrink wrap like
right but that's that's that that's the
dopamine speaking right
but as soon as i walk out it instantly
begins to diminish
and a day later it might still be there
but it has
been fleeting for an entire 24 hours a
month two months six months later
it's like oh i don't even care about
this right and then two years later it's
like
oh this stupid old phone and and so
i think it really depends on on the time
frame you're talking about
usually i i think that that that sort of
consumer high does not last
far past the checkout line yeah you
could tweet that podcast sean
we got a question here from eric in
seattle washington i kind of
find it surprising that uh the digital
environment is treated as a bit of a
panacea
junk drawer you can scan anything and
toss it into the
into the cloud but i feel like it
creates a lot of mental baggage for me
to just know it's out there
and wondered if you had any tips tricks
practices uh best practices on how to
appropriately manage
the bloating space of digital content
in our digital world so ron you talk
about
digital minimalism and i do think this
is something
that a lot of people are troubled with
especially when they start dealing with
the stuff i think we're most troubled by
the physical things because they take up
space they
they take up money they take up time and
attention but as we start clearing that
that
physical clutter we realize that that is
a physical manifestation
of other things that are going on in our
life so it could be mental clutter
spiritual clutter but it's also
digital clutter and so you've tackled
digital clutter
what do you talk to people about i think
to answer this question
of why you know we tend to have so much
of the digital things say to the cloud
is because of how easy it is to do it
you know it's it's easy to hit save
easy to hit upload and when something's
easy we don't think
think about doing it it becomes second
nature you just hit the button and now
it's gone
yeah and then you don't and because it's
not physical it's not sitting in front
of you
it's not tangible you can't touch it you
can't see it then you forget about it
so i think we have to first take a step
back
and and and analyze ourselves and figure
out why
we tend to do things so easily and then
two it does any of those
digital things whether it's images you
know songs whatever it is
do they also have an emotional
attachment to us of some sort because it
could be old family members could be mom
dad grandparents
and because the cloud is easy to save
too we just throw it there or i know i
still have it but i forget that it's
there
and i think that's the biggest piece
that we have to overcome is the easy how
easy it is to do it and then remembering
that it's still there yeah you know i i
to me
just personally i don't think digital
clutter is as troublesome as
as physical clutter and here's why if
you are able to put together and
i think it's more troubling for most
people because as you said they make it
easy but they don't necessarily make it
simple
and so it's just like i'll scan
everything i always throw it in the
cloud somewhere
and then it's like you have this this
orgy of content
that is like i don't even know what's
out there anymore i've just all
i've scanned it i've i've uploaded i've
saved i've downloaded it i just put it
in the folder and
you open the folder and it's just chaos
right
well that's easy but it's not simple
simple would be curating
that and and so what i do is i just
every file that i
i save i name it appropriately so i'll
give you an example
um with photos ryan i've just been going
through a bunch of
childhood photos because of our next uh
film
we talk a little bit about the time that
we we met in the fifth grade we were
literally the two fattest kids in the
fifth grade and uh we've actually found
some pictures and i
i think that kid would totally kick my
butt today
the the fifth grade version of myself he
was certainly bigger than me yeah um
well that mullet it was very it's
intimidating
i totally had a hell of a yeah it's so
sad
anyway um yeah so stay tuned to that our
next our next netflix film will have
uh incriminating evidence of both of us
yeah no i like what you're talking about
though about having a system
right and so the system the system i
have is a simple system
it it does you don't have to overly
complicate this thing but whoever's in
the photo and the year so if it was
uh josh ryan and sean
in 2019 that's what the photo will say
it'll also
often have a place that we're at too so
it's like uh josh mom
pool 1984 or whatever and and so
it's just enough so i have enough
information that i can search
for those things and and then for me
if i digitize something that is actually
a way
for me to let go as long as i have
organized it appropriately
now just organizing for the sake of
organizing is
is troubling you've talked about this
but
um if we if we organize things
carefully if we do so with intention
what that does is it gives me permission
to have that out there because you're
never gonna the same way you're never
gonna reach the end of the internet
i wouldn't be worried about all the
stuff you have in the cloud the same way
i'm not worried about like oh my god i'm
never gonna
i'm never gonna finish reading wikipedia
well no duh of course you're not that's
not the intention but it's
there if you ever need to access it yeah
i like how uh
he likens the the digital world
to a junk drawer because oh yes because
if we treat it like that then the course
is going to stress you out
and you know josh what you're talking
about is a very simple approach to our
digital lives
but simple is not easy and so having
this especially if you have
a junk drawer right now of all these all
this digital
assets whatever you want to call them
it's going to take some time to filter
through those
i mean it might take you a day or a week
or a month but you know
you if you are experiencing this mental
distress over your
over your cloud the stuff you have in
there then you've got to come up with a
plan to
simplify that right and i think i think
the add to that too
is also understanding that that process
is going to take time yeah it's not
going to happen overnight and i think we
get so overwhelmed because we want the
clutter to be gone now
right now right now so he's looking at
the cloud and he feels
overwhelmed by the cloud because he's
like i want to delete this i want to
organize it but i want it done now yeah
it's going to take time to go through
those thousands of photos or songs or
videos or whatever it is so you have to
be understand be gentle yourself that's
gonna take time to go through those
things
but like you said find a system of
organization that works for you
and the things that you want to keep 100
i mean think about how much time it
takes to
to uh collect all those photos and songs
i mean it's
yeah it happened overnight right right
exactly so so the last thing that i'll
talk about here
is you know what's fascinating to me
is yes we worry about these things we
want to hold on to everything and so
often we
we digitize it i digitize it for the
opposite reason as i said a moment ago
i digitize so i can let go no longer do
i have to have 2 000 cds i have
functionally infinite music
in my pocket you mean 2000 cds and
cassettes
yeah and alphabetized yeah so in high
school
josh was like he was ocd in high school
just like he is now yes
but every time he would buy an album he
would get it on cassette and on cd yeah
i literally spent all the money from the
restaurant i worked at just to buy
cassettes and cds um yeah it was it was
pretty terrible
yeah because like you're yeah your stair
your car stereo play cassettes yeah but
then you're sorry i really need the new
silk the shocker album
on cassette all right um
but i i digitize things so i i can let
go and what i mean by that is you also
have to realize that
if all of it were to go away i think
that's the ultimate minimalism
is realizing that i'm okay if all of it
were to be deleted i love that question
like what if it all spontaneously
combusted
what would you do right now and like
your your feeling to that answer really
lets you know
how important those things are to you
like i'll tell you this documentary
we're doing like matt's looking for some
photos
and i don't have a ton of stuff from
high school in fact he sent me a text a
couple days ago and he's like hey man i
need a picture
from when you're a fat little fifth
grader i could find i found one my dad
had
some of them but his house burnt down
last year
and i was a little you know a little let
down like oh man i wish i could give him
more of a
variety of pictures too some of the
documentary but you know you don't need
childhood photos for this documentary to
be great i mean it might it
will add value like i'm certain of that
uh to to show people what
josh and i look like in the fifth grade
but ultimately uh yeah i'm not that
upset about it
and just because something adds value
doesn't mean you won't be okay without
it and i think that's what
ultimately we need to realize is like if
if all of these things that are
digitized
they should they should add value they
should make my life better in some way
but i should also be okay if it all if
the if our website was deleted if our
entire podcast archive was deleted
i would be upset about that in the
moment but i would also be able to step
back
and and not be traumatized by it and i
think that ability to let go
actually makes the digitizing a lot
better for us
it makes it it makes it so that it makes
it so that we can let go in a way
well eric i'm going to send you a couple
things here let me give you a copy of
our book
essential it's an essay collection here
i'll hold it up for the youtube folks
it's 150 essays about living
intentionally there are 12 different
areas of intentional living
and one of those has to do with our
technology so there's an entire chapter
in here
about technology if you like our podcast
you'll really like the
audiobook version of essential it's over
six hours long or if you want the
the book book or the ebook version we're
happy to send those to you as well and
also since you're in seattle
we're headed out on tour pretty soon and
we're coming to seattle in a bunch of
other cities the minimalists.com
tour for anyone who is interested even
if we're not coming to a city near you
put in your email address there we'll
never send you spam but we will let you
know
when we're coming to a city near near
you but eric we're going to send you a
couple of tour
tickets as well to that event we're
gonna do a live podcast
we'll have a special guest maybe even a
musical guest etc
hope you enjoy that tour stop ryan what
time is it you know what time is it
you know what time it is you know what
time is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer your text messages
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts go
to both of our phones and we personally
respond to as many
as we can now ron during the lightning
round this is where ryan and i and our
guests
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response
uh mine today is actually about 280
characters i was looking at that i'm
like you took the
you took advantage of the new twitter
that's right
really we just we ramble on a bit until
we find something that is
pithy enough for sean to put in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media
so we got a question here from mahmoud
as a minimalist
is there any area in life where you
allow for more
rather than less now i'm going to give
this to you i'm just going to tee it up
with my pithy answer and you tell me
what you think this
is an excerpt from i believe it's
somewhere
one of our essays minimalists don't
focus on having less
less less they focus on making room for
more
more time more passion more creativity
more experiences more contribution more
contentment more freedom clearing the
clutter creates room
for the intangibles that make life more
rewarding and so i really think
minimalism is in many ways about more
right we often think of as this this
vector for less and that's true but
but it's what are we going to fill our
life with after that right yeah i agree
i think i think minimalism is not living
without just live with everything you
need
and i think when we step back and read
that podcast
yeah that's great when we step back and
ignore the less or more
statements in this and look at the word
enough then it becomes about us
so what is enough for you it's not about
how much do i consume of this or how
less do i consume of that
is how much do i consume that becomes
enough for me so i think if he
ignores the his question of
what what do you get more of in life i
think and just look at
what would be enough for me in my
situation in my life then i think he's
going to find the answer he's looking
for so for me
i don't i don't get more of anything i
just get enough of everything i want
or everything changes over time right so
so as your preferences change
maybe your interests change your hobbies
change your desires
change um even our impulses will change
and so we become different people over
time not
radically different necessarily but 10
years from now you're going to be
different from how you are today
and so identifying what is enough what
is enough today could be
too much tomorrow so we have to be
willing to let go
a day from now a week from now a month
from now a year from now i think that's
why it's
this sort of continual process you don't
get there to worry all right i've got
enough
and now life is perpetually perfect it
doesn't work that way
i think i think another thing i want to
say is to add to that i kind of look up
to look at decluttering
instead of going approaching it from a
perspective of okay i'm going to
declutter today
and then wait a week i'm going to have
another massive declutter a week from
now i kind of look at it from the
perspective of decluttering as i live
so anytime i come across an object or a
thought or a digital thing that i no
longer need or find value in
i deal with it in that moment so if it's
a thought i figure okay why am i having
this negative thought or this positive
thought
and how can i approach it or how can i
get rid of it if i come across a piece a
shirt or some jeans that i no longer
wear
it goes right into a basketball front
door and then it goes to goodwill at the
end of the week so
i think if you look at from perspective
decluttering as you live and another
thing i want to say
is when you think about the idea of more
um i always say in my content that you
know different phases in life require
different things and necessities
so just like you said things are going
to change it's always going to be fluid
and so you have to be able to change
with life and
you know i'm thinking through some of
the pieces that i say in my content i
always try to
entwine poetry somehow and i say that
uh change is gonna happen regardless if
you're ready to it or not it depends on
how you move with it
determines how it's gonna happen in your
life yeah so if you're rigid in your
life
change is going to happen no matter
around you so then you're going to feel
the
the effects of that yeah but if you're
fluid with it and when change happens
then you're moving been with it
and adapt as just as you're supposed to
yeah i think one of the biggest mistakes
i've seen people make with minimalism is
they look at it as a destination
we get questions a lot we're like oh
i've got rid of everything now what
and now i'm not happy right now i'm not
happy like now it's like that's the same
thing as i bought the thing why am i not
happy
thinking the the accomplishment the task
the completion and i get it especially
people like me i'm a bit of a completist
by nature but also realizing that like
that destination is not going to make
you happy
when i write a book it's not the
publication that makes me happy it's the
joy of the process
ryan and i have spent the last two and a
half years on
this next book that we're working on
called love people use things and
and you have to remember to stop and
enjoy that because when the book comes
out it's great that people get value
from it but the real joy comes from
from the actual creation of the thing
right yeah and i like what you said how
people look at minimalism as in the end
thing
and i like to say that minimalism is a
tool not the end result yeah so you
think about life you think about
building a house you have to lay the
foundation first and the foundation
comes from
our emotions and our mindsets so dealing
with those things and then when you add
minimalism to the mix
it's just a tool to help you build your
life it's not the end goal so that's why
it looks different for everyone
yeah so your tool could be a hammer your
tool could be a chainsaw mine could be a
screwdriver
just depends on how we make those tweaks
to our life using the tool of minimalism
yeah
absolutely i think whenever you give up
something
you're gaining something else i mean
even i think of like a monk who gives up
everything
their hair they give up all their
possessions like they're gaining
silence they're gaining time to
use however they want meditate whatever
it is so
uh it's when you're when you're getting
rid of
things when you're getting rid of the
excess you're you're gaining more in
some other way
uh my pet the answer is this y'all more
more freedom is more empowering than
more stuff
there's my more more and more answer
yeah
yeah it's it's finding that that right
more because also what you said a moment
ago ryan is is true
when you give up something you get
something but when you get something
purchase something you often give up
something you give up a piece of your
freedom
yeah and so it's like hey is this cup of
coffee worth two dollars of my freedom
is this toyota corolla brand new worth
30 000
of my freedom like how many hours do i
have to work
in order to buy the thing that takes me
to work
yeah um all of a sudden when you start
thinking about in terms of not
currency but a different kind of
currency what am i actually giving up to
get this thing
and sometimes the answers are gonna be
yes this is worth my two dollars of
freedom or ten dollars or a hundred
dollars or whatever
but making that that decision
intentionally as opposed to
well i guess it's five dollars and i've
got five bucks
that's not the most deliberate use of
your money all right well we got a whole
bunch more to talk about
i do want to talk to you ron about um
some specific things we can do
with respect to decluttering we're going
to get into that uh we've got some
listener tips as well today and our
added value segment but first it looks
like we've got a bunch more surprise
questions
this week like how do you practice
digital decluttering so we're going to
get specific
on some of the things that you do ron uh
in terms of digital decluttering
also how can we make meaningful
purchases based on
style and quality is there any stuff you
found
you truly need but wish you didn't
need is there a marie condo method for
social media
we'll talk about that also uh the only
thing i
over indulge in is books please help me
that's a question that someone had here
or a statement i suppose a cry for help
also 15 ways to simplify your life
plus a million more questions about
minimalism for ronald l banks and if you
want to hear all that check out our
maximal episode this week
on the minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast
and it's just two bucks and it's the
most honest way for the minimalist to
earn an income because
you know we don't believe in
advertisements we think advertisements
suck so we make money if and only if you
find value in
what we create and support what we
create head on over to
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get a personal
link so that our private podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from
our listeners check them out hi this is
emily mcgarmett from fairfax virginia
and this is in response to episode 245
where ryan was mentioning that he was
having difficulty
donating to goodwill i've had a lot of
success with buying nothing groups
and have been able to get rid of clothes
that way to
neighbors of mine that can use it and
that might be a good
option while the donation centers are
closed
hi my name is michelle and i'm calling
to answer a question asked on episode
97 by hustle from gene from sacramento
she mentioned moving into a tiny house
and the accoutrements that come along
with
the life-sustaining hobby of cooking she
asked
when you cook how long does it take you
and what do you make
in our family my husband and i arranged
for cooking for 20 minutes to hours and
even days for some of the recipes
i really wanted to call because my
husband and i
dream of having a tiny house and someday
with
half of it being the kitchen so i had
several recommendations for jeans
first was a kitchen supplies walton
brown's book
gear for your kitchen was really helpful
for me um he's very critical of what he
refers to as unit haskers or tools that
only do one job
second is a subscription to america's
test kitchen online
if you're shopping for stuff they have
really helpful reviews
and they've tested everything very
thoroughly
then for minimalist cooking the brothers
green eats on youtube has brief
well-made videos
and in the early episodes they're
cooking in a small apartment kitchen
so that may be helpful to you lastly i
would advise considering how everything
will work together
for example my husband has been pining
after an induction cooktop
if we were getting one for a tiny house
i would keep our pressure cooker
and eliminate our rice cooker
maybe invest in a pan that would nest in
the pressure cooker for storage
if we were instead investing in an
instapot or something similar
then i'd have a really different plan i
maybe want a
single gas burner in addition so i hope
for you everything that
is going well and you're able to make
decisions that help you downsize while
keeping your choices
on things that you value all right y'all
thanks again to ronald l banks for
joining us today check out his youtube
channel
we're gonna put a link to that in the
show notes ron thank you so much for
joining us for having me thank you very
much
we got an added value segment today and
so stick around for this i want to talk
to you about this um
our friend derek sivers who we did a
live event with i think it was his first
interview
in like four years or something yeah
yeah we did a live event with him back
in 2017. you can actually find it i
think it's episode
83 no that's not right 125
dunbar's number is real after about 150
episodes i started losing track of all
of them
i used to have them all memorized you're
malfunctioning i need to upgrade your uh
computer tip thank you uh we'll put a
link to his uh
the episode we did with him the live
event we did in the show notes but
that's not what my added value is today
he has a new book out it's called hell
yeah or no it might be his best advice
ever
right and so it's it's his essay
collection he's been working on three
books concurrently over the last i don't
know
five or six years i feel like only
sivers could do that
yeah well he works like him and maybe
seth godin right
well even even seth wouldn't do what
silvers does sippers is
he he works like 12 15 hours a day
and i love his writing process his
writing process
is beautiful so what he does is he
writes an outline
and then he expands on the outline and
gets many many pages
of the idea down he takes those pages
and he says how would i describe this in
a new outline
and then he just publishes the outline
and doesn't like
he just throws everything else away i
mean it's real minimalism anyway
his book and it's only available on his
website sivirs.org we'll put a link to
it in the show notes oh good friend
yeah it's awesome and i think if you buy
it you get the i just bought i just
bought a case of them so you you can buy
the physical version
he also has the e-book and the audiobook
that sort of come together
um and i mean what a great advice
so his advice of hell yeah or no has to
do with making decisions and so
he says no to everything unless it's an
absolute
hell yeah i'm definitely going to do
this thing i i have to do this thing
i'm excited about doing this thing he
also has contrary advice to that as well
when you should say yes to everything
and so he talks about
that as well so enjoy that book that's
our added value for this week hell yeah
or no
the new book by derek sivers and for
right here right now real quick here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists
we now have two youtube channels well by
the time this comes out because we're
minimalists
[Laughter]
uh you can subscribe to both or don't i
don't really care uh but
uh if you would if you if you're
interested we're moving the full
episodes of the podcast
we we spoke with some experts and a
bunch of different people who told us to
do this
and so it makes sense it's not like
we're creating more it's just
i guess youtube youtube's algorithms
have been punishing us because what
we'll do is we'll put these
half hour 45 or hour long podcasts on
our main channel
and then we have short videos on on
there as well and so like
it confuses it's just a better
experience for folks yeah and so if you
would subscribe to both of those that'd
be great uh
the current one is going to we're going
to keep putting out short videos on
there so quickie episodes living room
conversations
all the the short podcasts and and short
things that we do youtube videos that we
do
uh those will still be at youtube.com
the minimalist and then we have this new
channel by the time this episode comes
out
just for the minimalist podcast we'll
put a link to that in the show notes if
you
check it out both of those are still
advertisement free we don't monetize
either one of those
we just want to add value to your life
with youtube
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists ron you are
at i'm ron banks on twitter what are you
on instagram
at i'm ron banks iran banks across all
platforms there we go
you can follow you can follow ron there
on all those platforms
i'm ron banks follow the minimalists
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists
podcast i don't know we don't have the
url yet anyway youtube.com slash the
minimalist you'll find it there
somewhere and if you want uh i want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list
over at theminimalists.com you'll also
receive our simple
sunday emails and if you leave here
today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it